[Music]
hey gq it's jackson heller i'm a
colorist in new york city i've been
coloring hair for 10 years today we're
going to recreate tyler the creator's
leopard print hair on our client daddy
[Music]
let's talk about tyler's hair evolution
so 2011 mtv awards tyler got a hat on as
usual he just had a basic lineup and
a boring haircut
2014 a pink hat still same hair now this
isn't no shade to tyler but we just say
him he wasn't experimenting too much
2018
tyler at the grammys it looks like them
russian soldier hats or something and on
the red carpet he takes the hat off and
what do we have here
cheetah pride mm-hmm cheetah print
i want to do this crazy cheetah print
thing with all these colors in my head
yeah i think this would be a great look
for you just have fun with it now we've
got the look and these are the steps
before we start the color we're gonna
have barry cut the hair and give him a
clean shave step two bleach the hair
we'll then be ready to start the
coloring process step three tone the
hair step four apply the leopard print
pattern let's get started
[Music]
daddy what's going on baby
you looking good today thank you save me
i'm looking crusty
i'm probably gonna bring it down to like
a two or something like that there this
way the cheetah print reads clear i'm
gonna be using my wall scenes with a
number two guard on there and then if
that don't bring it down to the level
that i need it i'll use the one and a
half let's comb it out and see what you
got here
got a little more than i thought you had
[Music]
now i'm gonna use my and these t
outlines to clean you up so you can look
real young
[Music]
step it up gillette
so i'm going to use sea breeze they're
astringent just so you keep you from
bumping up or anything like that there
you know you look
like a young denzel
i think that finishes up what i'm going
to do for right now we're going to do a
second part of it after you get your
print and then i'll line you up and
clean up and make it look complete
[Music]
all right here we go
just start applying the bleach
you always want to like keep it off the
skin just so it doesn't cause any
unnecessary irritation
and with short buzz cuts like this you
should always kind of skim the surface
first with the bleach
and let that sit for a little bit
so that it can start to lift and then
you can fully saturate it down to the
root that way you get an even lift root
end
right now i'm just lightly placing the
product on the surface
and then i will go back through
and completely saturate all of it to the
scalp
is there any difference if they wash
their hair oh definitely yeah so before
a bleach it's a good idea to not wash
your hair let your natural oils kind of
build up because it will help to
minimize the itching
if you would ask me to do this back in
high school i would not do this i was
shy quiet and then one day i met the guy
who inspired this look on the street i
met ty with the creator one time
i asked him for an autograph and he was
like we could just talk and i was like
oh oh okay and we talked for 30 minutes
and it was life-changing and then i
stopped being shy and scared and now i'm
bleaching my hair thanks tyler
anytime you bleach the hair you want to
make sure you're using a moisturizing
product and oil is great as well this
bleach i'm using has a lot of moisture
in the formula the developer most of the
time my clients can't even feel a
difference in their hair texture
it's about not overlifting the hair we
want to lift the hair to
a pale yellow
and then we'll tone that to
a nice shade of blonde
all right 45 minutes with the bleach on
and then we'll shampoo and tone the hair
[Music]
all right so as you can see we bleached
the hair after 45 minutes we shampooed
now we're going to tone the hair
for yellow you usually want to
use a more violet-based toner
something that's just gonna cancel out
the unwanted warmth in the hair when it
comes to toning it's important to
customize the formula so that it's
special and unique but also suits the
client
they're really saturate always with
color in general whether it's bleach or
toner you get like a flawless evened
result
now we're going to wait 10 minutes for
the toner to develop and then we'll
rinse and condition
so as you can see we rinse the toner and
it's a creamier blonde now without as
much yellow
now we're going to add the design onto
the hair first step we'll be putting the
brown spots followed by the black spots
i'm using more toner a warm brown color
for the cheetah print and i'm actually
using like an actual paint brush just to
create the right shape that i want for
this design
i'm a canvas
this cheetah print i'm kind of doing a
bigger
scale instead of a lot of smaller spots
because i think it just reads better and
if it gets too busy it just looks messy
it starts off kind of orange but you'll
see as it oxidizes it starts to look
more brown as the processing time goes
on
so we'll let this sit for like seven
minutes rinse it off and then go on to
the next step
so now that the brown spots are on we'll
add the black outlines to the design for
this i'm just using black manic panic
the color is called raven and you can
definitely find this at your local
beauty supply
this is something that's like
technically high maintenance if you want
it to look like this all the time it'd
be like weekly touch-ups to maintain it
but i like when things fade and become
something different so now we'll let the
black sit for a few minutes and then
carefully rinse it off with cool water
so it doesn't stain the blonde and then
we'll bring barry back in to do some
final touches on the haircut
okay i'm getting ready to used
walls seniors and i'm gonna put a one
guard on it
and i'm gonna be bringing his size down
just a little
[Music]
so now i have my t outlines that i'm
going to start lining them up with
[Music]
i'm going to be using the bumbo bumble
silver wax i have just a little bit in
my hand and this goes a long way
[Music]
since he has waves it's going to make
his waves pop
see stick
and it gives a finished look
now i'm just going to take the shears
and just
get those loose ends
[Music]
and i think jackson did an amazing job
with this i'm a cheetah girl
[Music]
all right let's check it out cool
been dying to see this oh okay so this
is what y'all been looking at this whole
time
it's looking good it's looking good
[Music]
i love it i wasn't nervous but i was
skeptical because it's a lot but it
works my skin tone i believe in it it
looks great you look amazing for
aftercare i would just suggest use cool
water when you're showering and don't
shampoo it too much
thank you so much for letting me do this
i know it was quite a process jackson
thank you i put my life in your hands
and you came through you delivered you
look great until next time